don't if the liars come Annie must step
down the cry of angry students in front
of the Amir Kabir University in Tehran
strong criticism of Iran's supreme
leader the Revolutionary Guards are
deployed leave us alone at last the
crowd chants but the guards don't comply
tear gas is used to disperse the
protesters earlier Iran's military
commander in chief had tried to quell
ill feeling the tragedy had left him
inconsolable homini said in Los Angeles
Iranian Americans traditionally critical
of the regime gathered to call for
common ease removal they sent messages
of solidarity to the protesters the US
president - offered protesters his
backing even tweeting in Farsi that the
world is watching with people on the
streets in cities across Iran and calls
for new mass demonstrations on Sunday
all eyes will be on the regime's
reaction
[Applause]
I'm joined now by Abbas Milani he's the
director of Iranian studies at the
Hoover Institution at Stanford
University professor Milani thank you
for joining our program now just how
significant are these protests underway
in Tehran and are they any different
from previous ones I think they are
different than the previous
demonstrations particularly the previous
demonstrations two month ago where
essentially the dispossessed and the
poor the marginalized these are the
elite of the Iranian society and they
are objecting to the death of many of
the Iranians in recent airplane and they
are objecting to the fact that the
Iranian regime lied about its complicity
tried to hide it and has since been
absolutely Cavalier in its treatment of
the people who are mourning for the
death of their loved ones well right
after the United States assassinated
Iran's top general Soleimani there were
widespread anti-american protests there
was an outpouring of nationalist pride
and now it's just a few days later we're
seeing these protests against the
Iranian regime professor what do you
make of this shift I'm not very
surprised because I think the Iranian
people are wise people they were trying
to show the world that that don't want
war that they're against the fact that
the United State took upon itself to
assassinate the second most powerful
person in Iraq but at the same time
we're against this regime for his
corruption for its incompetence and for
the waitress Iranian people for the fact
that they'd lie but the fact that they
try to hide their complicity in this
truly remarkable event and the two are
contradictory but at the same time
they're part of the same complex Iranian
response to a very complicated situation
that we have in Iran today well we have
seen the Iranian Revolutionary Guards
actually issue an apology to the nation
they said they take full responsibility
for the accidental downing of the plane
I mean this is quite an unprecedented
gesture don't you think yes no yes in a
sense that they have finally accepted
the responsibility no look at the
Iranian social media because people are
angry that they only accepted this
because there were Canadian German
Swedish citizens in this tragedy and
hadn't been all Iranian there is every
indication that the regime would have
continued this effort to cover up if you
look at the first three days this regime
went out of its way to cover this up
they went out of its way to lie if we
read the reports that have just come out
from the Ukrainian officials the regime
tried as the Ukrainian team arrived in
to lie about every aspect of this these
things are known in Iran and they make
the Iranian people angry all right
professor Abbas Milani we thank you very
much indeed for being in our program